[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
the velvetia is one of the strangest
plants in all of the world
firstly because they're unusually ugly
of course that might be a matter of
opinion they've got two large strap-like
leaves that continuously grow from a
short woody unbranched stem along the
ground
over time the ends of the leaves die and
dry forming a twisted and frayed bundle
at the base of the plant like a big
rat's nest
they're also interesting because they
live a very long time
carbon 14 dating of the largest plants
have shown that several individuals are
at least 1 500 years old some are
believed to be as much as 2 000 years
old making them the oldest plants in the
world
even though they've got a shallow
taproot these incredible plants survive
and thrive in the deserts of namibia
where temperatures can easily reach
130 degrees
how do they do it
during the night and morning they absorb
any moisture in the air
that's a good lesson for all of us to
make the most of what little we have to
get through fiery trials
what do you think pastor ross is some
things we can even learn from an ugly
plant like that absolutely i mean when
you look at the pictures you don't think
well there's not much to look at but
it's a fascinating plant for one it
lives a very long time more than 1500
almost 2 000 years of course redwood
trees are known to also live for a very
long time but here is a plant almost
just like a bush yeah like a plant
something else interesting about the
plant i was looking at it's it releases
a red pigment when it's very hot in its
leaves and the leaves actually turn
reddish which helps to reflect the
radiation of the sun and when it's
cooler in the desert areas then it
releases more chlorophyll and the leaves
turn very bright or deep green which
helps to absorb energy so
uh and i'm guessing that they must taste
awful or some camel would have eaten
them that's what i'm thinking some
animal would eat it but it must smell or
taste terrible leave them alone
so here we have a plant that's able to
endure incredible hardships it patiently
waits until the moisture comes and it's
able to just thrive under these very
difficult conditions it reminds me of
some christians who are able to thrive
even though they're going through some
difficult trials yeah when i lived up in
the mountains
i lived in the desert mountains for
several years
and uh well about a year and a half they
have barrel cactus up there
and during the dry season they shrivel
and they get skinny they got pleats in
them
and then if you have a rain in the
desert there's you know a day or two or
a few hours of rain you'll see them they
soak up every drop of water and they
literally they swell up and they slowly
then use that water to uh survive
so that's what a christian needs to do
as long as we can we need to soak up the
living water the word of god and
store our minds with truth to get us
through the times of trouble the reason
that noah survived the flood is because
he stored it with food and resources he
couldn't drink the salt water to get him
and the other animals through that storm
and friends now is the time for us to be
storing up the truth of god's word
and the living water of god's spirit to
get us through the the fiery trials that
come there's a verse in the bible pastor
ross it's in first peter chapter 4 verse
12 and 13.
beloved do not think it's strange
concerning the fiery trial that is to
try you as though some strange thing has
happened to you
but rejoice to the extent that you
partake of christ's sufferings that when
his glory is revealed you may also be
glad with exceeding joy god promises he
can get us through those fiery trials
and those trials actually shape and
prepare us
absolutely we have a book that gives
encouragement some biblical principles
of how we can endure trials and
difficulties the bible tells us everyone
who chooses to live a godly life
will experience difficulties and trials
so how we to react when these things
happen the book is called when the brook
dries up that's why do christians suffer
and i think it'll be an encouragement
for for anyone going through some
difficulties
i just call and ask we'll be happy to
send this to anyone for free the number
to call is 800 835 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called
when the brook dried up and i think it's
referring to the story they passed out
of elijah when he was right or during
the three and a half year drought in
israel when god provided water and food
at the brook but then the drug
dried up yeah and yet god had another
plan for where he was to go yep he he
always if that happens he will uh supply
another way and he did absolutely again
we want to welcome those who are joining
us on the various outlets those joining
us on amazing facts tv we are live and
we're welcoming your questions also
those listening on radio both in various
local stations and on satellite radio on
facebook pastor doug batchelor facebook
page as well as the amazing facts
facebook page so again welcome thank you
for being a part of the program if
you're the duck bachelor now youtube
page too oh and the youtube page that's
right we're also on youtube if you have
a bible related question the phone lines
are now open so this is a good time to
pick up your phone and give us a call
the number is 800-463-7297
again the number is
800-463-7297 with your bible question if
you don't get through right away stay on
the phone and one of our phone operators
will answer the call as soon as they can
well pastor like before we go to the
phone lines we always like to start with
the word of prayer so let's do that dear
father once again thank you for this
opportunity that we have to be able to
open up your word and study together and
lord it's your book so we ask for the
holy spirit to come and guide us lead us
all into a clearer and a full
understanding of bible truths found in
the scriptures be with those who are
listening wherever they might be and we
ask this in jesus name amen amen
we're going to go to our first caller
this evening we have uh risen in uh los
angeles california is a welcome to the
program
god bless praise jesus thank you pastor
doug thank you pastor ross
uh it's been a year or so
since i uh spoke with you but i don't
want to go around the bush
i want to go direct to my question
because i know you have a lot of
people who want
sure last question
i have a question about
jewelry
i i heard your message about jewelry
and you said the jewelry
cost people
to have pride
i will jewelry pastor doug
in
did we did we lose you are you there all
right go ahead
so you wear jewelry are you wondering if
it's wrong to wear jewelry
i i wear jewelry in
moderately okay
and jewelry gold around my risk reminds
me of heaven
that i'm gonna be walking in the street
of gold it doesn't give me pride at all
well
so are you one you do you want me to
give you the bible reasons yeah do you
want me to give you the bible reasons uh
for what i said
i'm not done with my question yet if you
if you can finish me up okay
uh
in the bible there are references about
jewelry like the prodigal son the father
gave his son
a ring when he came back to him
and also in psalms
uh
we gave it
it's full of jewelry there too
so
i don't know what's wrong with jewelry
when it comes to moderation
uh
killer
so go ahead pastor dog
all right thank you
yeah no i appreciate it and a matter of
fact i could even add to your argument
um
it tells us in ezekiel about how god
adorned his bride with jewelry
and so i'm not denying that people in
the bible wore jewelry and let me make
it very clear in case anyone out there
misunderstands there's gonna be a lot of
people in heaven that wear jewelry
so uh yeah i don't know i've answered
that question many times so i don't know
which answer you heard sometimes it
focuses on a different aspect of it but
i was saying that there are a number of
scriptures in the bible
that talk about jewelry being connected
with pride
and one of them is in isaiah chapter
i think it's isaiah chapter three it
says the daughters of jerusalem
are proud and they go walking and
mincing as they go and uh and it
describes all their jewelry in detail
um and then you can even read about
lucifer it talks about all the precious
stones that covered lucifer
when the children of israel went out of
egypt
jewelry was money in bible times because
they had no paper money and so they used
to trade with jewelry
when eliezer wanted to give
a dowry to rebecca it says he gave her a
bracelet it tells how much it weighed
because it was it was money
the children of israel ended up making a
golden calf out of their jewelry and
worshipping it
and so
many christians through history have
believed that because of statements
where paul says let the adorning not be
the outward adorning the wearing of gold
and putting on apparel and paul talks
about not with gold or pearls or
precious adornment but with modesty
and so people they're wondering well if
i just wear a little bit modestly how's
that
um
i take the position
that you know how much is too much
so by the way i have a book written by
the same title and you may have read
that
it's called jewelry how much is too much
and the reason is that
uh sometimes by your example some people
they you know they're concerned about uh
their appearance they have slow
self-esteem
and they you know they put on a lot of
jewelry um
and it can be a stumbling block for
somebody so to avoid
having anyone else stumble and let's
face it a lot of people wear a lot of
bling
and they spend a lot of money so you
know if something's going to make your
brother stumble don't do it paul says
you know if eating meat's going to make
my brother stumble he's talking about
eating meat off her to idols he said i
won't eat it i don't want to do anything
to make my brother stumble
there will be people in heaven that
drink alcohol i don't drink any alcohol
because some people will get addicted
and it's a bad witness i also think
there's good health reasons
so um
i think the reason is you know for
christian modesty a few years ago i'll
say one more thing on that
a few years ago a number of
televangelists got into trouble uh they
fell morally and it became very public
and but the same televangelists they
were always parading their
their rolexes and talking about their
bentley cars and their wives were always
dressed in very flamboyant attire lots
of jewels and
and the world was making fun of them and
they said you're begging for all the
money from these poor people and look at
how you're you're be decked
so i've always taken the position that i
think if a christian is going to make a
mistake make a mistake on the side of
modesty
god is not going to say to me when i
stand before him in the judgment doug i
can't let you in why not lord you didn't
wear enough jewelry
so i know some people out there think
well you're you're kind of radical but
maybe
well you know god knows the human heart
better than we do yeah and if god asks
us not to do something ultimately it's
for our own good you know we find an
example in the bible in exodus chapter
33 before the children of israel were to
enter into the promised land one of the
things that god told them to do is
remove all of your jewelry and he knew
that that would be a stumbling block for
them and of course like you say we want
to set a good example for those around
us so a reason i'd encourage you to call
and ask for that book it's called jury
how much is too much and that's for
anyone wanting to know what does the
bible say about this topic the number to
call is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called jewelry how much is too much
we've got mark listening in tokyo japan
that's where the olympic games were mark
welcome to the program
yes hello uh pastor uh
uh doug and uh pastor uh john yeah sean
um
i'm from i'm in uh actually mitaka tokyo
uh we're right next to the park where
the bike rack uh
bike races began the olympics went off
yeah all the way through
around mount fuji to the uh
kofu area
and uh
boy i don't i don't know how they didn't
keel over in the heat but
they made it so that's good
that's good well we're glad you got a
front row seat there
uh
actually my question is
i think it's a very simple one but yet i
get so much opposition in this question
and uh in this in this particular bible
verse and it's ecclesiastes 9 5.
for the living know that people die
but the dead know nothing
and they
have no more reward for the memory of
them is forgotten and what i'm having so
much opposition is the very last verse
of for the memory of them is forgotten
my version is the memory of the person
that is deceased that is dead that is
now sleeping
their memory is wiped out and gone but
i'm getting people saying it's the
memory of people
that are alive that knew them
and i'm thinking well my parents died
many years ago and i still remember them
so i'm not
somehow or other
i need clarification on this particular
which what is me what is it what is
forgotten when it says the memory of
them is forgotten you know i'm looking
at the young's literal translation here
and it words it for the living know
they'll die but the dead no not anything
and there is no more to them a reward
for their remembrance has been forgotten
and i think if you go by this solomon is
saying it could be taken one of two ways
solomon i think here is saying
that you know over time
people
do forget about the living
but i think it also could be said that
that person's memories
uh they're not thinking
anything when they're dead
so it doesn't mean they're not going to
be resurrected to have any memories but
it just means that they're not
remembering anything when they're dead
so there's kind of two ways you can look
at that verse but either way
fits with you know good theology and of
course the memory of those are forgotten
it's talking in general terms there are
certain individuals i mean our family
members are parents
that we would remember but even if you
think back you know four or five
generations even in your own family do
you remember unless you're in the
history of books yeah your ancestry so i
think he's talking in general terms the
reality is that when a person dies their
own memory ceases in death but over time
their their contribution to this life
uh is also forgotten unless it's
interesting unless they played a role in
helping to lead others to christ and
then that gets perpetuated right so we
can i have a memory and that is in
sharing christ with others
does that help mark
yeah so so in what you're saying is
really it it's kind of a dual answer
it's really uh the dead the person that
is now sleeping memory is now forgotten
and then the people over time and
forget about them
and what they what their actions and
what they've done on earth yeah solomon
you look at the the uh
what do you call it the context of
everything he's saying in chapter nine
he's saying the important thing is
his life
he says to all the living there is hope
for a living dog is better than a dead
lion
uh you know and he says uh
several times he talks about you know as
a man dies so dies a beast
he's saying you know if you're if you're
making your treasure down here it's
really a waste because this life is
temporary that's what he's really saying
he concludes the whole book by saying
what's the conclusion fear god and keep
his commandments for this is the whole
duty of man for god will bring every
work into judgment with every secret
thing whether it be good or evil so he's
basically saying don't live for this
life alone think about the life that
will last because you're going to die
and this life will be over
so but if you fear god and keep his
commandments there is a judgment and
obviously there's a judgment there's a
reward so that's how he concludes the
whole book
all right well thank you for your call
mark you know we do have a study guide
it's called are the dead really dead and
he talks about the subject of what
happens when a person dies we'll be
happy to send this to anyone in north
america the number to call is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called are the dead really dead we also
have a website it's called
deathtruth.com and of course you can
access this website anywhere around the
world
and it's filled with all kinds of
wonderful bible verses sermons study
material so if you want to learn more
about the subject take a look at
deathtruth.com
next quarter that we have is robert and
he is listening from let's see
robert is in washington uh robert
welcome to the program
yes hello thank you for taking my call
sure
okay yeah i have a question for um about
isaiah 65 verse 23
yeah it's uh
they shall not labor in vain or bring
forth for trouble for they are the seed
of the blessed of the lord and their
offspring with them
okay i had always
understood this to be talking about the
survivors of the seven year tribulation
period
and this is talking about the
thousand-year kingdom
and
those are the children born without
trouble
what is your take on that
all right great question um keep in mind
isaiah is prophesying before the jews
were attacked by the babylonians he
lived quite a while before that but he's
foretelling a time
when they would go through a great
trouble
but
there would be another period of peace
when they would come back and their
descendants would be blessed and that
was during the time of ezra nehemiah god
watched over them
but it's really a bigger picture of
talking about heaven
and you can read here if you go back to
oh
verse 17 for behold i create a new
heavens and a new earth and the formal
will not be remembered nor come into
mind
and so he begins to talk about just
there'll be no more weeping
in jerusalem
my people will be a joy
you know it's like jesus said there's no
more pain or suffering or sorrow in the
in revelation 21 and 22
so it says i'll not plant and another
eat they'll not build in another inhabit
they used to plant their vineyards and
then they like in the story of gideon
the midianites came and took all their
produce or they chased them out they'd
move into their houses
and he said you will long enjoy the
fruit of your hands now i don't think
it's saying there's going to be new
births it says you and your offspring
meaning you and your children
will enjoy the the benefits of this
eternal peaceful kingdom but i think
that's after the millennium yeah if you
look on a few more verses verse 25 says
the wolf shall lay down with the lamb
and they will feed together so that's
clearly talking about uh the earth made
new at the end of the 1000 years it's
also interesting specifically pastor
doug 23 it talks about um you shall not
bring forth children for trouble and
your descendants will be blessed to the
lord your offspring with them so you
know the family unit will still be
intact in heaven that doesn't mean that
you're going to be giving birth to
children in heaven uh the children that
you have here that perhaps will be alive
when jesus comes or have died and are
resurrected the children will grow up in
heaven but the family unit will still be
blessed and there won't be any fear for
the future yeah and it's actually the
it's the antithesis of what jesus said
on the way to the cross he told the
daughters of jerusalem don't weep for me
but weep for you and your children
because a great trial was coming here he
says your children will be safe right it
doesn't mean they'll be procreating it
just means that you'll your children
will be safe in the new kingdom they'll
have peace
all right well thank you cool robert
hope that helps we got uh jose or joseon
josie i think it is in washington
jos josue welcome to the program
hello
hi welcome
now how do you say your name
um you say it josue josue okay thank you
yeah
my question is on first samuel 28 okay
and my question is
how
would i explain to a new believer
that
because in that chapter um saul wanted
to get to samuel
but he wasn't alive
and so how would i explain to a new
believer
that samuel wasn't alive but the bible
says he was for example in verse 15
he said and samuel said to saul
how would i explain to someone like that
yeah well i think that for one thing the
context is does a witch have the power
to resurrect a believer
does the devil have the power to
resurrect a believer and i think the you
know the un unspoken answer is well and
that would really be bizarre i think
it's saying this apparition that looked
like samuel so for the means of telling
the story they got to say what do you
call this apparition
you know it claims to be samuel
uh and there's another place that pastor
ross i think is going to right now in
chronicles where it explains what saul
did and it says
saul actually died not just because of
his pride and his rebellion
but because he went to a medium
and
he was consulting evil spirits the bible
says do not go to a necromancer somebody
who speaks to the dead paul said that
people when they worship idols they
don't realize they're worshiping devils
and the bible talks about
satan and his devils that work miracles
satan himself can be transformed into an
angel of light
you know satan can
bring down fire from heaven and create
illusions
and so there's just a lot of scriptures
that uh explain that there are evil
spirits
that can masquerade this way you have
that pastor ross um i'm just looking for
a pastor i found the one in first samuel
which is what we're talking about let me
see if i can pull it up here i i'm
familiar with that verse
so yeah i hit the wording just right
yeah talks about how yeah here it is
first chronicles chapter 10 verse 13.
that's the one it says
um
it says so saul died for his
transgression which he committed against
the lord even against the word of the
lord which he kept not and also for
asking counsel of one that had a
familiar spirit to inquire of it so
there we it says it's not law
it's a familiar spirit and that's what
they use for demons and fallen angels
does that help a little bit huswei
yes it does
all right thanks so much for your
question we do have a lesson on the
witch of indore
and um it's in the historical series of
the landmark uh series and it's called i
think the witch of indore
if you'd like to learn more about that i
think in this case go to the amazing
facts website you can actually read the
lesson for free online
and it's called the witch of endor it's
part of the historical set of lessons of
the landmarks that have lessons name
both of those next quarter that we have
is john and he's listening in florida
john welcome to the program
hi pastors how are you doing doing
really well thank you
well i'm calling on behalf of my wife
we've been
studying and uh
we're i'm not as knowledgeable obviously
as you guys
and uh
she's wondering why seventh-day
adventists keep uh catholic holy days
such as
easter primarily but christmas and i
guess these were based on pagan
holidays and her
from orthodox they follow different days
obviously than they do here in america
all right well let's jump in here first
of all
yeah the seventh-day adventist when you
say keep them we don't we don't uh
we don't have a special mass on
christmas or easter uh
we meet in other words there's if
easter's on wednesday i don't know any
churches that say let's get together on
well easter's always on sunday isn't it
i don't know any churches that get
together on sunday yeah yeah christmas
on on wednesday we don't all flock to
the church and and uh have a mass or
anything like that so
we certainly don't and whether or not
it's one denomination or another we want
to know what the bible says right
that's the main thing
exactly
so i don't know you want to jump in
that's right yeah you know i think it's
important for us to understand a little
bit i mean we're quite open and honest
we don't believe jesus was born december
20 what is it the 24th of december we
don't believe jesus was born december 25
and i think there's some good biblical
reasons for that we know the history a
little bit about that and of course
easter um to peg it to one particular
uh weekend uh it still moves in the
calendar so even east is not exactly the
time i mean if uh you go by the days
they'll move throughout the week
and they pick a sunday and they say well
this is yeah it may not land on the past
doesn't always land on a sunday but
you know i think there's nothing wrong
in celebrating or remembering the
resurrection of jesus that's an
important event also remembering the
death of jesus but to keep that day as a
holy day as sama being a sacred day i
think that's that's the issue that's the
concern yeah there's no bible command to
do that
but it is a scriptural event
so you know if
if you want to remember the thursday
when jesus had the last supper well i
guess he can't no one else celebrates it
but i think we ought to preach on
everything jesus did
and but um yeah there's no
um
there's no command that we're supposed
to celebrate his birth on one of the
things we're trying to do past today
talking about that around easter time
we try to do a communion service some
are connected around that time of the
year now of course we don't always get
it on the day it doesn't have to be on
the exact day but it's kind of neat when
the rest of the world is talking about
the death burial and resurrection of
jesus for us to recognize that through
the institution that christ himself
established that's not a sin to give
somebody a present on the 23rd of
december yeah
you know if people are giving presents
in in remembrance of god's gift that's
probably as good a time as any well you
know we do have a book it's called uh
what is it called feast days and
sabbaths no wait there's another
baptized paganism that's the one i'm
thinking i was looking for here that
actually deals with some of this and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks just ask the
book called baptized paganism and the
number for that is 800-835-6747
all right friends don't go far we're
just taking our mid-term break and we'll
be back in a few moments with more bible
answers
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time for more
information visit kingdoms in time.com
really wanted to start a new devotional
habit but life got in the way next thing
i know we're a month into the new year
and i'm like what's the point of
starting then i saw 365 amazing answers
to big bible questions each day is a
single study so you can start anywhere
on any day and not miss a thing they're
crisp clear and enlightening
get yours today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit af afbookstore.com
the jews are some of the most unique and
gifted people in the world and even
though judaism is one of the smallest
religions about 16 million globally they
still manage to have a profound impact
on history wherever they go
yet even though most of the bible was
written by jews and jesus himself was
jewish the jewish people can be among
the most resistant to the christian
religion well friends this is why
amazing facts has recently produced a
fascinating three-part dvd series called
is jesus kosher for jews in these new
programs steve wohlberg jeff zerminski
and myself all who share jewish
background relate our personal
miraculous journeys of faith in a
winsome way and we consider together the
controversial question
are jesus and judaism compatible
you will personally be inspired by these
life-changing stories call today
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends we're just so thankful
that you're joining us for bible answers
live and we're very thankful now that
we're on tv we're on af tv that you can
not only see on the galaxy 19 satellite
i think you just go to
aftv.org and watch it streaming
they can see it on youtube
facebook doug batchelor facebook amazing
facts facebook and we're going to
continue to expand the stations that
will not only play it on radio
but be playing it on television i'm doug
batchelor my name is john ross and again
we want to welcome all of those who are
joining us we have a number of folks
waiting online so we're going to go
straight to the phone lines past doug
should we tell people that at the end
we're going to take a bonus question oh
that's right yes i nearly forgot about
that so for those of you who are
listening on radio we're going to have a
short break right at the end of our
program but don't go away because we're
going to come back with a very
interesting bible question now there
might be some who are listening on
satellite radio and you might lose just
that last question but for those who are
listening social media amazing facts tv
and other radio stations you'll probably
be able to join us for that bonus
question so stand by for that i'll be at
the end of the program so what if
someone do if they want to send us an
email if you want to send us an email
question to get on that bonus question
every week all you'll need to do is send
an email to bal questions at
amazingfacts.org
you see the lower third there on on the
screen
bal questions at amazingfacts.org and
we'll try to answer as many of those
bonus questions as possible all right
very good thank you we've got miss rowe
listening from virginia
miss rowe welcome to the program
hi thank you very much for taking my
call
yes we're glad you called in yeah
my question is i want to know if jesus
is abiding in me it's been three years
since i studied the bible and i want him
to abide in me but i'm the master of my
heart i feel and i love jesus but i
think i i i love myself more i choose to
serve myself more than i should to serve
him i have some improvements in some
areas but i feel like i don't do those
things with my effort i mean i do those
things with my effort rather than
depending on him it's hard to obey him
and often fail to do so i pray and enjoy
studying his words and i desire to know
him not as knowledge but with my heart i
want to really know him but i know that
i don't love with the love of jesus i
don't endure with this endurance and i
don't obey the way he did when i asked
others i'm told that the fact that i
want him to abide in me is exactly the
proof that he does but i don't
and and i don't want to doubt it if he
does but i also don't want to assume and
be confident about it
or if in fact i don't let him yet so
what do you think
yeah great question um
you are not alone there's a lot of
people out there they they want to love
jesus more you know if someone came to
christ and they said lord what's the
greatest commandment jesus said
love the lord your god with all of your
heart mind soul and strength and love
your neighbor as yourself
loving god with all is a full-time job
and so for the the christian
you always want to be uh feasting on the
word looking to jesus talking to jesus
and it's it's an ongoing discipline
because
in this life
you know we're weak the devil is
constantly trying to distract us and
derail us and god's very loving and
patient so don't get discouraged
but you want to grow as a christian and
so
you your devotional life the three most
important things you can do to grow
spiritually is
read the word pray
and share your faith do something to try
to help others love the lord and love
your neighbor
so yeah go ahead you know we've got a
book past today it's called three steps
to heaven and i think it emphasizes
those very three things that you're
talking about the importance of prayer
bible study sharing our faith and it's
an ongoing experience the apostle paul
this champion of faith and you just look
at the things that he did he is a
prophet inspired by the spirit
and yet he said i have not obtained he
said i die daily so it is an ongoing
daily experience where we have to
surrender ourselves to christ and uh we
might not be where we want to be but we
should by god's grace not be where we
started out there should be spiritual
growth christian life is paul says it's
a fight it's a race it's a wrestling
match and you know
it it but it's still a lot better to be
a christian than to be lost in the world
and be a slave of the devil
so you know there's some struggles but
uh
feast on the word and don't give up you
know every every christian has those
mountaintop experiences where you sense
the presence of god and you're filled
with joy and you know it's just
wonderful but you also have those
moments where
you don't feel that close to god it's at
those times that you need to exercise
faith and believe his word that he said
he'll never leave us nor forsake us and
hold on to his promises absolutely
so hope that helps a little bit ro get
that book three steps to heaven it's
free just request it we'll send it to
you the number to call is 800
835-6747 you can ask for the booklets
called three steps to heaven we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks we've got jill listening from
new york jill welcome to the program
hi good evening
good evening
and your questions hi um sean ross i
remember talking to you off the air and
doug basher i remember you praying for
me off the air years ago too i'm also
blind visually impaired so bear with me
um in first john 2 15 it says love not
the world
nor anything in the world if anyone
loves the world of love of the father's
not in him now how do you balance that
with john 3 16 for god so loved the
world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life and
then i have another verse in question
with that
all right well
as far as loving not the world
and uh then god says god so loved the
world when the bible tells us you know
you look at the context of how
something's being used
uh when the bible tells us to love not
the world it's talking about worldliness
and then is it james it says if any man
loves the world the love of the father
is not in him
god wants us to love lost people that
are in the world and god so loved the
lost people in the world jesus came to
seek him to save the lost it's not
talking about the sin in the world
because that world is going to pass away
and the lust thereof so he's defining
what about the world is going to pass
away the sin and the lusts of the world
will pass away but he that does the will
of god will abide forever again that's
john chapter first john
2 verse 15 through 17. and the famous
verse john chapter 3 verse 16 for god so
loved the world it's talking about the
people in the world it's not talking
about the rocks he loves people he came
to save people yeah and we ought to have
that same love for people but there's a
difference between loving people and
loving the evil things worldliness
that's right which is different yeah
there is a difference so you had the you
had another second part of the question
yeah um
yeah matthew 5 44 kind of kind of maybe
answers your question a little bit it
says but i tell you love your enemies
and pray for those that persecute you
that you may be sons of your father in
heaven but then in james 4 it says
friendship with the world is enmity
towards god
yeah well yeah you caught it so we we
kind of touched on that verse um the the
lord wants us to love everybody for the
purpose of saving them it doesn't mean
we love evil and we certainly don't
endorse bad behavior
but
matter of fact one place god said to was
it king jehoshaphat
why will you be friends of those who are
enemies of me
he was making the league and supporting
ahab so we're not to love worldliness
okay jesus died for all sinners
uh we've got barrington listening from
new york barrington welcome to the
program
good evening pastors
evening uh my question
my question is this um
the baptismal the baptismal formula in
matthew 28.
why the disciples didn't follow that um
baptismal formula when they were
baptized in acts
the book of acts yeah well you're
correct that there's no record of the
disciples saying we baptize you in the
name of the father son and holy spirit i
don't think that we should assume that
they never did
so in acts i believe it says three at
least three different ways it says
baptized in the name of the lord
baptized in the name of jesus
and so the exact wording is different in
almost every case i think two of them
are the same in acts
so i wouldn't get hung up on the wording
you know when christ said baptize in the
name of the father son and holy spirit
and then in peter it says to be baptized
in the name of the lord
and it says baptized in the name of uh
jesus christ in acts chapter 2 verse 38.
so
uh are you thinking that it must be
uttered a certain way or you're just
wondering why there's different terms
yeah because jesus says in in matthew 28
all authority is given to him in heaven
and on earth
so
why why not baptize in his name
well i think that the disciples did
baptize in the name of jesus
well in our church we try to cover all
the bases
we say i'm baptizing the name of the the
father's son jesus christ and the holy
spirit
yeah but um
yeah i also think in acts there's a
clear distinction being made you're
right we ought to baptize the name of
the father son and holy spirit and i
think that's very clear in matthew
chapter 28
it's not saying that the disciples never
prayed that way or baptized i should say
that way but i think the point that
obviously was in contention at the time
of the early christian church
was jesus and his position as the son of
god as the savior of the world most of
the jews accepted the fact that god is
god the father is god
but it was the jesus question that
raised a lot of disputes so i think
where we have it mentioned in acts
chapter 10 verse 48 uh luke is just
making it very clear that these were
people being baptized into christianity
into christ and that was the point that
was being emphasized yeah i just looked
it up real quick um it says baptized in
acts 2 38 in the name of jesus christ
acts 8 16 baptized in the name of the
lord acts 10 48 the name of the lord
acts 19 5 the name of the lord jesus so
the wording is a little different but
i think that they the idea is are you
being baptized into the name of
the the god of the bible and the messiah
jesus as pastor ross was saying so
um
you know let me just give you an analogy
real quick
that's not something we should get hung
up on because baptism is very much like
marriage it's a public covenant that
you're following jesus
and pastor ross and i are pastors we're
ordained we do weddings
and when we do a wedding the important
thing that wedding covenant
is that the two individuals getting
married know who they're making the
covenant to
some weddings i might say bill do you
take sally it's a little informal
other weddings i might say do you uh
william
from randolph hearst no not him but
anyway you know mary mattina
james or whatever you know just the
whole name and it's very formal
either way you do that wedding when they
say i do and there are witnesses and
they sign that document they're married
so
you know the the wording in the ceremony
is never emphasized in the bible as that
is supposed to be the important thing
they all knew they were getting baptized
in the name of jesus christ
and father son and holy spirit the god
of the bible
you know we have a book called baptism
is it really necessary i've actually
pardoned me oh we have another i've got
a book called the name of the lord there
you go the name of the lord talks about
baptism and what name do we get baptized
in that might even be a better book i
mean both are available you know you can
ask the name of the lord or the book
baptism is it really necessary for those
who aren't baptized we want to encourage
you to prayerfully consider this it's an
important step and you might want to
call and ask for that book and then also
ask for the book it's called the name of
god the number to call is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for those free books
if you're outside of north america you
can still read it by simply going to the
amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org
next quarter that we have is james
listening from uh new orleans james
welcome to the program
are you maybe you're muted james you
there good evening
i'm here can you hear me uh you're
popping in a little bit so yeah state
your question and we'll do our best to
answer it
thank you sir
uh my question is is there any
opportunity to be saved
the rapture is there an opportunity to
be saved after that is going to be saved
okay we're going to bring your volume
down your your phone your cell is having
a problem
um
if you look in 2 peter chapter 3 it
talks about the day of the lord coming
as a thief in the night
in which the heavens pass away with a
great noise and the elements melt with
fervent heat the day of the lord is when
jesus comes back you can read in a
second i'm sorry first thessalonians
chapter 4
the lord will descend from heaven with a
shout the voice of the archangel the
trump of god and the dead in christ will
be caught up that's the rapture we get
caught up
what happens at that time
thessalonians says the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming
and so
no i don't believe there's any chance
once the lord comes and people are
caught up we're of the opinion that the
tribulation happens before
they're raptured up not after so you go
through what we call the tribulation the
bible speaks about the seven last place
being poured out god's people are
protected during that time just like the
children of israel were protected when
the ten plagues came upon egypt then
they were delivered after the plagues so
god's people are protected during those
seven last plagues but then when jesus
comes um the righteous are caught up to
meet the lord in the air the wicked are
destroyed at the brightness of his
coming ii thessalonians tells us we also
need to remember that just before jesus
comes there is a universal death decree
according to revelation chapter 13
passed against god's faithful people so
jesus comes to the deliverance of his
people
and the wicked are then destroyed with
the brightness of his yeah it's not just
the jews yes some of my
friends believe it's yes it's talking
about any believers you know pastor i
think this is important this is an
important bible truth for people to
understand i've actually heard people
talking about this and he wasn't a
believer but she was and his argument
was well i'll wait until suddenly she
disappears and then i'll know that what
she says is real and i'll get my act
together and i'll seek after god repent
during the seven well it's gonna be too
late right yeah i mean when jesus comes
there's no second chance so it's a good
point to bring up james something that i
think we need to study out we do have a
uh a book on the topic it's called
anything but secret it's talking about
the second coming of christ and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the number again is 800
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
anything but secret and of course you
can read it outside of north america
just by simply going to the website yeah
of course if you're in north america you
can read it too at the website we've got
derek listening in minnesota derek
welcome to the program
oh hi thanks for taking my call i had a
question and it's sort of like you know
how the first angel message mirrors the
sabbath commandment
um i notice in genesis in the new king
james version genesis 6 or 3 16
and then in genesis 4 7 like the 3 16 it
talks about um like eve and the desire
will be for the husband and he'll rule
over you
and then when you go to genesis 4 7 it
says like send lights on the door
and it'll be
your desire and it'll rule over it or
something like that it's weird how it's
like the language is kind of mirrored in
both of those verses and i didn't i
didn't understand it like is there some
like symbolism symbolism there
you know that's a good point um of
course
uh you know one is a statement where god
is talking about the um
the real consequences of sin in genesis
chapter three
with cain he's saying that a sin wants
to have the mastery of you but you
should rule over you should subdue it
don't resist it
and he would not resist his pride and
that sin he ultimately killed his
brother but you know i is there a
connection between those two uh i can't
spot one right now sure i mean the verse
the wording is similar but the wording
is similar but i think the
probably the idea in my understanding is
when it says sin lies at the door and
it's desirous for you but you shall rule
over it it's kind of referencing that
carnal nature that that sinful nature
that we we've inherited shall not have a
minion over you yeah we've inherited
from from uh you know adam and eve and
our parents all the way down but the
bible tells us that by god's grace we
are to rule over it in other words it's
not to rule us right so it's not a sin
to be tempted but by god's grace we are
to resist that temptation we are to rule
over that temptation
and that's what we find in this verse
yeah well thank you derek we've got a
lot of calls lined up we're going to try
and get a few more in we've got sherman
uh sherwin i should say listening from
canada sherwin welcome to the program
hi good evening pastor ross and pastor
doug evening
hi my question is about the the sancti
uh
the justification and sanctification so
i've always believed that justification
sanctification sort of a linear process
but now i'm thinking so every time i sin
really i get justified if i ask for
forgiveness um and then
and then so on and so forth
it's
it's looking like it's more recursive or
it's in a cycle
rather than it's linear
and then eventually glorification comes
so my my confusion is is the
justification and simplification process
is
linear or more of a recursive all right
i think i understand what you're saying
let me give you another way to look at
it uh you know when jesus died he
provided justification for all that
believe and i'm looking at three verses
in romans that talk about the romans 4
25 romans 5 16 romans 5 18
talks about resulting in justification
of life think of justification as that
through the blood of christ he filled an
ocean
that will wash away sin
uh that he does that once
we may need to jump in that ocean
several times
and have that justification renewed
but you know he was justified once in
another he provided
this justification for those who will uh
take advantage of his offer
when he died on the cross and he died
for the sins and he poured his blood out
and it was adequate for the whole world
at that point
but you know you and i often have to
renew our justifications why paul said i
die daily dying daily is not just
sanctification dying daily is asking for
i want to be resurrected new life and
and have a refreshed justification you
know we have a book that you wrote past
today it's called assurance
justification made simple and deals with
this very subject and i think uh anyone
would be encouraged by reading this the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the book
written by pastor dag it's called
assurance justification and sure one in
canada can read that online that's right
we can send it to canada anyone in north
america so yep you can read online or if
you in north america we can send it to
you we've got david listening in hawaii
david welcome to the program
hey pastor thanks for having me yeah um
my question
is in regards to the 2300 days in daniel
chapter 8. um specifically how does it
ties to the day of atonement um the
context in daniel chapter 8 is that the
sanctuary is being cleansed because the
little horn has desecrated but the
context of the day of atonement is that
it is being cleansed because of the sins
of the repentant also the word cleanse
um is not the same hebrew word in daniel
chapter 8 verse 14 as it is when it's
referring to the day of atonement
and lastly why is the day year principle
applied when it says evenings and
morning and we don't apply that to other
prophecies like jesus's prophecy about
being buried three evenings and mornings
or in the creation account
okay oh you got several questions there
hopefully we can we'll try and cover
some of it can i start with your last
one though
uh the last one you talking about why do
we apply the the day for the year
you you know either way you do it if in
daniel chapter 8 it's talking about the
ultimate cleansing of god's people which
occurred on the day of atonement the day
of atonement happened once a year
so if you say that this is 2 300 years
are days rather and you apply the day
for the year principal
well then it's 2 300 years
if you say well it's 2 300 days of
atonement
and the day of atonement comes once a
year it's still 2 300 years because
you're talking 2 300 days of atonement
they come once a year so i think it's
real easy to support the that this is
speaking of a year
the other thing is jesus he did use the
day in the year uh christ after john the
baptist was arrested jesus told his
friends i think this is luke chapter
three let me see there's a luke chapter
13 i forget he said if you type in the
word fox you'll find it
jesus said go tell that fox that i teach
and do cures and cast out devils today
and tomorrow
and the third day i'll be perfected
that's luke 13 32. thank you yeah so it
wasn't jesus did not teach three more
this is six months into his ministry he
did not teach three more days he taught
three more years but he was making a
prophecy
so the only way daniel 8 works is if you
do apply the day for the year and the
context of it is the ultimate cleansing
of god's people and of course we only
apply the day for a year principle when
it when we're talking about bible
prophecy and clearly daniel is a
prophetic book there's a lot of imagery
that's used you wouldn't apply this
prophecy talking about the six days of
creation because that just
wouldn't make sense so instead of
talking about six days try and make it
six thousand
it doesn't work because for example you
have vegetation created before you have
the sun so i mean that's clearly six
days and of course then the the seventh
day got rested and he blessed and he set
it apart can i make a suggestion i want
to try and get one more call pastor ross
david we have a magazine that we just
came out with it's called divine design
and it goes into daniel chapter 8 in
great detail you've asked some great
questions we need 25 minutes to answer
your question they're more than that
so please look at the magazine and i
think it covers all of your questions
and that'll let us take one more caller
okay absolutely we've got let's see
we've got jalen listening in atlanta
georgia jalen welcome to the program
hey how are you guys doing today
good thanks for calling and your
question tonight yes
yes sir i'm gonna make it quick so it's
on time um can you hear me well we
all can
beautiful beautiful so i've been doing a
um i actually saw a video about um
tithe and i heard you speaking uh miss
passado
about it
and so i just did some research just on
it
um because there's a lot of controversy
on it and when i did my research however
i pinpoint tied to just mean
produce grain
livestock oil uh
wine
and um the only time i see
tithes mentioned with money however
is when i see it says in deuteronomy it
says if the journey be too long
you should fail your time you know
coming from agriculture that they have
right
and you can use the money and go to
wherever the lord that god put in you
can buy wine strong drink but that's a
whole nother subject but anywho
you can that's the only connection i see
with ties with money and it was for the
levites you know they were increasing
they were right so i want to wrap it up
we're going to run out of time so i've
got to oh yeah
so my ques
oh i'm sorry you got to just real quick
yes sir yes sir my question was how does
pastors receive tithes if they were for
the levites and pastors don't come from
the tribe of levi and whatnot and it was
all right money
let me let me answer that as quickly as
i can you're right it was an
agricultural society many of the people
the way they would pay tithe on their
increase and there's a lot of verses on
that you can read malachite says bring
all the tithe into my storehouse is
they'd bring their grain and so forth
clearly by the time of christ
they were giving money you've got the
widow that gave her two mites when she
came to the temple and the priests would
they'd cast their gold into the temple
the levites you could pay
money
they had a temple shekel and
even deuteronomy talks about that that
people would pay
uh it was the main idea was to support
the priests so that they could continue
to minister to the people through the
year
and so they would bring ties whether it
was the grain or the sheep the
agriculture or
you could trade that in for money the
thing was they were to be supported of
the increase we've got a lesson on that
called in god we trust we'll send you a
free copy and the number to call for
that is
800-835-6747 again you can ask for the
study guide is called in god we trust
it's a pretty exhaustive study on the
subject of tithing and what is the
responsibility for a christian so call
and we'll be happy to send that to you
amen well friends this is about the
fastest hour in the week it seems like
we just built up momentum and the hour
is gone
we are coming back in just a moment with
another bonus bible question but we've
got to sign off with our friends who are
listening on satellite radio right now
otherwise stay tuned we're coming back
with some internet
bible questions in just a moment
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back for our bible
answers live bonus question now again if
you have a bible question and you'd like
to send it to us you can email us by
simply
emailing your bible question to bal
question
amazingfacts.org and we'll try to take
as many of those in this segment of the
program here we go pastor first question
for tonight are aliens real
well angels could be accused of being
aliens and so does god have life on
another planet i believe yes
how do angels visit our world
yes and we know they're good angels evil
angels have been cast down to earth
according to revelation 12. i don't
think ufos and e.t are coming but i need
to let our studio know oh he's doing it
okay i want to see how much time i had
left on the clock
um but no the people that says i had a
ufo where i was captured by aliens and
they did experiments on me i'm very
dubious that that happened
okay next question that we have we're
going to try and get to many as we can
do i have to go to church to be saved
well there'll be i think there'll be
people in heaven that didn't go to
church because you know the thief on the
cross was saved in the final hours of
his life
there are people who maybe are sick and
they can't physically go to church or
they're so far removed from a church
they can't attend
and that will not be an obstacle to
their salvation but
if a person loves the lord and if jesus
said the church is his body and we learn
to love the lord by loving each other
and if the church is the medium through
which god communicates the gospel of the
world
why would not a christian want to go to
church
and so i'd i'd wonder about if a
person's committed to following the
bible he said
in especially after covet everyone's
wondering do i have to go to church to
be saved friends
we need to start getting back into the
habit as you know your local laws allow
do not forsake the assembling of
ourselves together and the sabbath was
called a holy convocation there's
something that happens jesus said when
you come together in my name we need to
come together in the name of the lord
and you know we can even sense it in our
in our congregation in our experience
pastor that when folks have been
separated from each other for an
extended length of time even though they
might be watching online
you begin to i don't want to say grow
cold but your your spiritual
fervency can begin to diminish if you're
not inspired by others who believe the
same thing who want to worship god where
you sing together we pray together it's
it's needful for a christian we can't
live by ourselves yeah we need the we
need the accountability we need the
encouragement and pray for one another
and so yeah i think it's real important
to come together
friends we want to remind you this
program exists entirely because people
like you
uh believe in what's happening here we
are 100 supported by supporters and so
thank you so much you can just go to
amazingfacts.org
and
uh donate keep us on the line god bless
we'll study next week
[Music]
you